many college students are just weeks
away from hearing commencement speeches
at their graduation ceremonies James
Ryan delivered a memorable address last
year the Dean of Harvard's Graduate
School of Education introduced the world
to his five essential questions in life
my claim is that if you regularly ask
wait what
I wonder couldn't we at least how can I
help and what really matters when it
comes time to ask yourself and did you
get what you wanted out of life even so
your answer will be I did so the poem
asked Ryan's message still resonates
today it's been viewed more than eight
million times on the school's Facebook
page Ryan has written a book about the
concepts called wait what and lies other
essential questions Jim Ryan joins us
today welcome thanks very much I
absolutely love this absolutely love
this cuz we're in the business of asking
questions saying wait what wait what
wait what however you start this book
with a promise that if you get into the
habit of asking these five questions you
will live a happier and more successful
life right wait what yes I believe that
I believe that if you get in the habit
of asking these questions in particular
wait what I wonder couldn't we at least
how can I help and what truly matters
those lead you to some of the most
important topics you can think about in
life and I do think if you live a life
fueled by those questions you actually
will be both more successful and happier
drue thousand me a link to your video
about a year ago and said you got to see
this yeah and the success has been
amazing what do you think it is so I
have been really surprised and
pleasantly surprised by how much this
resonated so you mentioned that it's
been viewed eight million times but I
also received countless emails from
people from all over the country in all
walks of life I heard from teachers I
heard from students I heard from
business executives I heard from parents
I heard from lawyers I heard from judges
I heard from Pasco so why they said that
they found the questions incredibly
useful so some teachers turned the
questions into posters that they are
hanging in their class
rooms some business executives said told
me that they had organized an entire
retreat around the questions another
business executive said our office motto
has now become couldn't we at least so I
think it's because the questions are
simple easy to remember and they're
applicable across a lot of content the
first three questions wait what I wonder
and couldn't we at least all three of
those are about questioning the
circumstances or surroundings yes do we
as humans not do that enough in this day
and age I think not nearly enough
so I think that kids are great at asking
the question why I mean it's a question
that every kid asked and I think that to
many of us as we get older become less
curious rather than more and stop asking
those questions and I also think that
some of the questions waitwhat and
couldn't we at least in particular are
great questions for this moment in time
because they are the first is a way to
seek understanding wait what right
you're slowing down to make sure you
understand something and couldn't we at
least as a way to seek common ground and
in an age where we are so polarized
trying to understand something before
you decide whether you agree or disagree
searching for common ground
I think we don't do nearly enough your
book opens a lot with you as a child you
asked a lot of questions I did ask a lot
of questions yes so many that my father
who who was very mechanically inclined I
was not my father told me from a very
early age that I had better become a
lawyer because he couldn't imagine but
earning a living any other way have you
have four kids we have four now are you
getting a taste of your own medicine
absolutely you know and my mom used to
tell me when she was alive that she
loves seeing the payback because my kids
ask a lot of questions wait what in
particular which is why that's the first
question like we're getting in the car
not wait yes yeah it's only quote the
simple truth is that an answer can only
be as good as the question asked so the
reminds me I think was Albert Einstein
who said asking the right question is 95
percent of getting to the right answer
exactly right and I and I bet all three
of you appreciate that because you spend
a lot of time thinking of great
questions to ask and you're exactly
right Einstein famously said that he had
an hour to solve a problem and his life
depended on it he would spend the first
55 minutes thinking of the right
Shinda ass because once he had the right
question it would only take him five
minutes to solve the problem does higher
education need to formalize this kind of
the study and the learning around
question asking
I think it's baked into any good
education and I actually think that we
need to start earlier in the k-12 on k12
classrooms and continue to cultivate the
curiosity that kids bring with them to
school every day this is so Aristotelian
of course asking the right question and
curiosity and to follow on on Alex's
point how does curriculum encourage this
in children oh so I think curriculum
that is inquiry based right that is not
just about filling kids heads with facts
that they need to memorize but instead
is asking them questions I think the
best way to teach kids about asking
questions is to ask them questions
themselves do you feel like in the field
of Education you're an expert here that
there's enough consensus about what kids
need at this particular moment where
things need to be pretty fractious I
think that there's a decent amount of
consensus but I also think we are at a
moment in time where there's an awful
lot of debate about exactly what should
be taught take a look at the culture
that we have
I mean is it in terms of raising kids in
terms of distractions in terms of
Technology does that aid the asking of
question does that in a sense take that
curiosity out of us well I think it
requires paying attention and and
teaching kids about the right questions
to ask I mean within this slew of
information it's easy to get lost and it
requires slowing down and thinking about
what are the right questions to ask and
what are the questions that are likely
to lead me to good answers how can I
help is one of the questions yes it is
so this question obviously is about
helping and and offering assistance is
one of the most humane instincts there
is but asking how you can help I think
it's just as important as offering to
help and by that I mean too often we
assume what someone else needs and don't
stop and first ask them how can I help
you
so I tell the story in the book of my
cousin Tracy who would come home from
work and explain to her boyfriend why
she had a bad day and he would
immediately try to solve her problems
and he's and she would say I didn't need
him to solve my problems I just needed
to listen if he had instead said well
how can I help he would have given her
the opportunity to tell him to tell him
how she can just given married couples
all my advice yes for solving real talk
how can I help it's not going to get you
a drink right okay so much no my
pleasure thanks again and wait what is
on sale now